The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GEORGE VERGHESE: I
want to actually spend
a little time, not
too much, talking
about discrete-time
Fourier transforms
versus discrete-time
Fourier series.
You don't have any
basis for comparison,
but I think the way we've
told the spectral content
story this term is quite a bit
simpler than in previous terms,
but that leaves you puzzling
over chunks of the notes
and practice problems that refer
to the discrete-time Fourier
series and to periodic
signals and so on.
So I just wanted to give you
a little insight into that,
and then we'll go on to
talk about modulation
and demodulation some more.
OK, so we've seen that
our interest is generally
in signals of finite duration
because practical computation
has to deal with that.
And so we've got
signals of this form--
0 outside of some window,
and really without loss
of generality, I can take
it to be some window from 0
to L minus 1.
If the signal shifts
in time, we know
what to do with the
Fourier transform.
Can you hear me all right,
by the way, at the back?
Yeah, OK.
All right so if we've
got non-zero values only
over a finite range,
then the computation
of the discrete-time
Fourier transform boils
down to a simple
finite computation.
Now, what we'll typically
do is give ourselves
a little more flexibility.
Since the signal is 0 outside
of this interval anyway,
we might sometimes
allow ourselves
to think of the signal as
being longer, but still
with zeros out here.
So you might come all the
way up to some P minus 1.
And what we're saying is, this
is the window of interest.
Everywhere outside of this
window, the signal is 0.
Now, the signal can be 0 at
various points inside here,
as well, but what we're saying
is, outside of this interval,
the signal is 0.
Therefore, I only need
to compute this from 0
to P minus 1, all right?
And the nice thing
is, it turns out
that you can actually recover
the time-domain signals
from the samples of the
DTFT through the formula
on the right side.
So what we're doing
is we're actually
computing the DTFT
just at isolated
points on the axis
between minus pi and pi,
just P, capital P, points.
Or you can think of them as
points on the unit circle that
correspond to each of
those exponentials that
appear in the Fourier
transform definition.
And we then recover the
time-domain signals just
from those samples, OK?
And really what's driving this
is the fact that the signal is
0 outside of a finite window.
OK.
We'll also typically-- and
if you look in the books,
you'll see this, as well--
this notation often gets
simplified, so x of omega sub k
gets simplified to just x sub k.
It's the k-th
spectral coefficient.
All right, so all that is good.
And we have this nice algorithm
for computing things, which
is the fast Fourier transform.
So we talked about
how that significantly
reduces computation.
Now, there are properties
of these formulas
that you can explore, and
I have some listed here.
I'm not going to
go through them.
They're essentially
the same properties
we've seen for the DTFT.
I want to focus more on this
formula for reconstruction
of the time signal from
the spectral coefficients.
By the way, in a previous
writing of this formula,
I had written the upper
limit as P over 2.
It's actually P over
2 minus 1, so I'll
fix that in the earlier slides.
OK, so what you're guaranteed is
that if you apply that formula,
you will recover every signal
value in this window of length
capital P. But what happens
outside of that window?
Well, if you look
at this expression,
is the right-hand
side here periodic?
You should suspect that it
is because of the e to the j
something n is there, right?
If you look at the
definition of omega sub k
and look at each of these terms,
it turns out that each of these
will repeat periodically
with period 2 pi.
Sorry, with period-- let's see.
I've said it badly.
This whole term will repeat
when n increases by capital P,
all right?
So let me write it down.
And why is that?
Well, omega sub
k is 2 pi over P.
So if you increase
time by capital P,
you're going to increase
the exponent by 2 pi,
and you've got the same
exponential back again.
And you can do this for any
integer multiple of capital P.
So what that tells you
is that the expression
on the right-hand
side is actually
going to repeat periodically
outside of this interval.
So it's fine to use
this formula to recover
the values in this
window, but if you start
to evaluate this formula
outside of that window,
you're going to start getting
this whole thing repeated
periodically, so
you're going to get--
at this point you'll get--
and so on, OK?
So the formula doesn't
know what to do except
to replicate periodically.
It's up to you to know
that this formula is
no good outside of this window.
All right?
There's another way to
think of it, though,
which is that this
formula gives you
a nice, compact representation
for a periodic signal.
So if you started off
with a periodic signal,
here's a way to represent it
as just a sum of capital P
exponentials, and that's
what a Fourier series is.
So you've seen in
1803 or other places,
in continuous time I
imagine, that if you
had a periodic signal
you could represent it
with a Fourier series.
This is actually
a Fourier series
for this periodic signal.
But if you know that
your action of interest
is all in this finite
interval within one period,
then you can actually use
the Fourier series just
to study what goes on
in that one interval
without worrying
about what's outside.
And that's really what
we've done this term,
is we've kind of ignored
periodic signals.
We've said all the attention
is in a finite interval.
Within that interval, we have
this Fourier representation.
It's easily computed by the FFT,
and everything works nicely.
So just to give a concrete
illustration of how we end up
applying this in a
particular situation that
should be familiar, if I had an
input going into an LTI system
producing an output, and if the
input was non-zero only from 0
to, let's say some n sub
x, and if the unit sample
response of the system was
zero only from 0 to n sub h,
is there a particular
interval of time
that you can
guarantee for me will
contain all the non-zero
values of the output?
I want you to find for
me an interval outside
of which the output
is guaranteed to be 0.
Anybody?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE: Yeah, good.
There are many ways
to think of this.
One is to say, well, the
input value at time 0
fires off a unit
sample of duration,
goes from 0 to n sub h, and
then the input value at time 1
fires off a unit sample response
that starts one time later,
and so on.
So each of these fires off
a unit sample response.
Well, you've got
inputs extending from 0
to n x, and so
you're going to have
an output that extends from
0 to n x plus n h, all right?
So you're guaranteed that
all the action of interest
happens in this finite interval.
And given that that's the
case, you can actually--
whoops, what happened?
You can actually do this kind
of spectral representation,
use the FFT, and all of that.
You're going to just work
on a finite interval, 0
to P minus 1, defined by that
or greater than that, OK?
So this is actually one of the
most frequent uses of the FFT.
It's to study systems where
all the action happens
in a finite window and
you know a priori what
the length of that window
is, and you can then
do all your computations there.
And you never look
outside that window
because you've already
guaranteed that everything
of interest happens there.
But when you read
the notes, you'll
find it's essentially
the same story,
but when you talk
about Fourier series
you're actually talking
about the whole signal,
the periodic signal, all right?
One bit of notation, also,
as you're reading the notes,
just to go back a second here.
We've been working
entirely in terms
of these samples of the DTFT.
When you're thinking of
Fourier series, when you're
thinking of this as
a Fourier series,
it's typical to write
X omega k over P
as just the Fourier
coefficient, A sub k.
So you'll see in the
notes an A sub k.
That's just a normalized
version of the Fourier transform
sample, OK?
All right.
That's as much as I
wanted to say on this,
so let's get back to
talking about modulation
and demodulation.
If you have questions
on what I talked about,
you can bring them
up in recitation.
All right, so just to
review where we are.
We've got some signal,
x of n at baseband.
Baseband just means that
its frequency content
is centered around zero.
You've not done any
modulation or shifting yet.
You've been allotted some
part of the frequency axis
to do your transmission in
because someone's told you,
perhaps, that the medium
that you're going to use
can only transmit in
that range, or the FCC
has decreed that you're only
going to use that region.
So you want to send
that signal somehow
in another frequency band.
So modulation was
a process by which
we converted up to
some carrier frequency,
and then demodulation was
what you did with the receiver
to get back down.
So just to look at that
in a little more detail.
This is the modulation process
we talked about last time.
You've got a time-domain
signal, your information signal.
You multiply it by
the cosine to get
an amplitude-modulated
transmitted signal.
So t of n is the signal
that you transmit, OK?
There are other names for this.
This process of
multiplying a signal
by a cosine at a
particular frequency
is referred to as heterodyning.
That's a term from the earliest
days of Amplitude Modulation,
I think invented by Fessenden,
who also invented AM,
and of course it's specifically
amplitude modulation for us.
All right, so just
to think spectrally,
we had a simplified version
of this picture last time,
but let's first assume that this
signal has some spectrum, which
is shown by a cartoon here.
I'm assuming a real signal.
So we know that the spectrum
has a real part that's even
and an imaginary
part that's odd,
and that's what's shown for
you here on this figure, OK?
So we're going to track
the spectrum of the signal
by tracking the real and
imaginary parts separately
because the spectrum is in
general a complex function
of frequency.
We've seen last time
what happens when
you multiply by the cosine.
You take the spectrum,
and you replicate it
at the locations of the carrier.
So if your carrier
frequency is omega c,
here's your frequency
band, going from minus pi
somewhere there to
plus pi somewhere here.
You've got a plus and minus
omega c, the carrier frequency.
So what happens
when you modulate
is you take the spectrum
and you plunk it down
on plus omega c
and minus omega c,
and you scale by 1/2, all right?
So if the real part
had amplitude a before,
it now has amplitude a over
2, and the imaginary part,
similarly.
I haven't drawn these to
scale, but hopefully the labels
are clear enough.
OK, so the modulation
is not simple
when you're thinking of what it
does in the frequency domain.
Now, it is not simple, but this
picture is a little deceptive,
perhaps, because I made an
implicit assumption here.
Otherwise, the picture
would be a bit messier.
What am I relying on here
to get this simple picture?
Yeah?
Sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE: Centered?
What's centered at zero?
Oh, the spectrum here?
OK, yeah, the spectrum
centered at here
gives me a simple picture, yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE: OK, exactly.
You see, when I
drew this here, you
can still recognize
the triangles that
came from over there.
But if the baseband signal
had a frequency content that
extended way over, then
the replication that I have
here would actually leak
into the replication
that I have there, and I get
a more complicated picture,
all right?
So if you want the
simple picture,
you actually have to limit
the frequency content
of your baseband signal, OK?
You can see here,
if the signal only
extends omega c on
either side, then I'm OK.
The two replications will
not smear into each other,
all right?
So we need a limit on
the frequency content.
Now, the specific
limit that you have
depends on the application.
We'll see later when you
do frequency-division
multiplexing,
where you're trying
to put many different signals
in the same general frequency
band, that the restrictions
might be different.
But the basic idea
is this, that you
want any replication
of your signal,
if you're going to extract it
later on downstream somewhere,
you want the replication to not
be corrupted by images of it
somewhere else, or images
of some other signal.
So actually, the example
that I showed you last time
wasn't perfect in
that regard, right?
Remember, this was the spectrum
of our typical baseband.
We had 256 samples,
like this, and then 0's.
And we looked at the
spectral content.
It was given by a
sinc-like function,
and this is the spectral content
magnitude after modulation,
and therefore it's
the two replicas.
I'd modulated this onto
a 1,000 Hertz carrier.
So this is what we saw.
And you can see here that
there's funny stuff going on
in here because the tails
of the two replications
are merging with each other, OK?
So it's not perfectly
symmetrical around here.
And actually, these sinc-like
functions decay very slowly,
so even though it won't
be visible to your eye,
there's a considerable
amount of this
that's actually due to
the replica out here, OK?
So this case doesn't
quite satisfy
that band-limited condition.
If you shape your
pulse a little bit more
carefully, for instance, if
you had more rounded edges,
then you can pull in
the frequency content,
and you might do a
better approximation
to keeping the replica separate.
Or you might use a
higher carrier frequency.
That pull them apart and
have less interference,
but it's certainly an issue
that you need to think about.
OK.
So what happens at the receiver?
We already saw this briefly
at the end of lecture.
If what you receive is what
you transmit-- in other words,
if it's the signal, then
extracting the x of n is easy.
We said what you
do is you basically
do the same heterodyning
again, right?
You take the signal
that comes in,
multiply it by cosine of
the carrier frequency.
That's your signal
after demodulation,
and a little bit of algebra
shows that you actually
have your original
signal of interest,
and then something that's
your original signal
modulated by a cosine at
twice the carrier frequency.
So now there's some hope
that you can actually
pull these things apart.
All right.
So one question,
of course, is what
does the spectrum of this look
like, and we'll look at that.
And then the other
question is, again,
what constraint on the
bandwidth of the signal
that you originally sent
from the transmitter--
what constraint is
needed to recover?
So let's look at the spectrum
of the received signal first.
We're assuming the
channel is not distorting
and that we don't have
noise, so what's transmitted
is also what's received.
So here is the spectrum
of what's received.
It's exactly the spectrum I
showed you earlier, right?
It was the baseband spectrum,
but replicated at plus omega c
and minus omega c.
So this is what comes
in off the channel,
assuming no distortion.
And I'm going to
multiply it again
by a cosine at the
carrier frequency.
So what is it that I have to do?
I take this entire
spectrum, plunk down
a copy centered at plus
omega c, and another copy
at minus omega c.
Because my demodulation,
just to remind you,
my demodulation
is multiplication
by cosine omega c again.
It's a multiplication
by cosine omega c.
Well, we know what that does
in the transform domain, so
here is the picture.
And the piece that we
want is the center piece.
So what we need to
do is filter it out
of what's resulted
from the heterodyning.
So what kind of cutoff frequency
would you-- what kind of filter
and what kind of cutoff
frequency would you want?
Any suggestions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE: Sorry, I didn't
hear where that came from.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Lowpass filter?
GEORGE VERGHESE: Lowpass filter.
So, for instance, an
ideal lowpass filter
would be great, right?
If you had a filter with a
frequency-domain characteristic
that was perfectly flat in
some region and then cut off,
let me say, at some
frequency omega 0,
so something like that-- well,
actually, we want a factor of 2
to compensate for the
demodulation process,
if we want to get exactly
the same thing back.
So this would be in
the frequency domain.
Ideal lowpass filter.
And we know how to get
approximations to this, right?
Because this is not
really implementable.
If you wanted to implement
this, what kind of unit sample
response would you need?
A sinc function, right,
but extending infinitely
in both directions.
But we could truncate that
sinc, and we could shift it
forwards in time to get a causal
approximation to this filter.
And the resulting
frequency response
will, if you plot it out, if
you compute it and plot it,
won't look too
different from this.
If I plotted the
magnitude, you'll
get-- it's something that's
a plausible approximation
to this lowpass filter.
But what cutoff
frequency would you want?
What omega 0 should you pick?
Any suggestions?
Anybody?
We're trying to
extract this piece.
So omega c would be a
pretty safe choice, right?
Omega c would be one that passed
everything here, and would
basically extract
any signal that
satisfied that initial
constraint that we mentioned.
So if your baseband
signal originally
extended from minus
omega c to plus omega c,
then a lowpass
filter that extracted
that would do fine
without pulling
in any of the replication here.
So omega c is certainly fine.
But if the signal that you
transmitted at baseband
actually had a narrower
bandwidth than that,
then you might just
want to get away
with a lowpass filter
with a lower cutoff.
Can you think of why you
might want to do that?
Is there anything
that motivates you
to use as small a
bandwidth as possible?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE: To limit
the amount of noise, right?
We suppress noise
in this whole story.
So if you're going to
build a filter like this
but all the interesting
action is over here,
well, all of the
rest of the filter
is doing is letting other
signals get in, especially
noise, and then that's
going to add to the output
and make things more
difficult. So you'd really
like to get the
smallest bandwidth that
suffices to pass the signal part
of what you're interested in
but keep out the
noise, all right?
But if you didn't know
anything about the signal
and its spread, or you believe
that the spectrum extended
really from minus omega
c to plus omega c,
then you would want to
make omega not equal
to the carrier frequency, right?
But you've got to look at
your particular situation
and see what it is
you're going to do.
OK, so this is the picture
that we have at demodulation.
You're going to take the
received-- well, no, sorry.
This is the modulation part.
Ah, no, it's not.
Sorry, this is not well-drawn.
That shouldn't be x sub n.
That should be the
received signal, OK?
So the received signal comes
in, gets multiplied locally
by cosine, gives you
the demodulated signal,
and then you have
the lowpass filter,
so I'll change that
before I post it.
Simple enough?
OK.
Now, there are some problems
that you can run into,
and doing all of this in the
lab you actually see that
very quickly.
So let me actually put
this on the board here.
What we said is that our
demodulated signal is
going to be our received signal
times cosine omega c n, right?
And if we assume no distortion
in the channel this,
is x n cosine omega c n.
But there's a bit
of a problem here,
which is that,
even if you've been
told what carrier frequency
your center is going to use,
you might not know
exactly what phase.
It's typically the case
that you don't know what
the phase is on this cosine.
So you know omega c, but you
don't know exactly the phase,
which means that your local
carrier, your local oscillator
or your local carrier
multiplication here,
will end up having some offset
relative to the carrier used
at the transmitting end, OK?
And so the question is,
if we track this through,
what happens through the
demodulation process,
so that's really what
this is trying to do.
So we're saying d of n
is your received signal,
but the local oscillator or
the local cosine that you're
heterodyning with
at the receiver
doesn't know exactly what phase
was used as the transmitter,
so you've got to
assume that there
is going to be some offset.
So this is actually what
the multiplication is.
And now you use a
simple trig identity.
It's the cosine of something
times the cosine of something.
That splits into this.
And so what we're actually going
to get from the heterodyning
at the receiver is x of
n times all of this, OK?
So what we're going to get is--
I should write it down here.
We're going to get 0.5 x of n.
And then there's
two pieces here.
There is the cosine
phi, and then there
is the cosine 2
omega c n minus phi.
OK?
When you don't have
any phase error,
the cosine phi term is 1, but
now it's reduced from that.
The rest of the
process is the same.
You're going to do some
filtering to get rid
of this piece, the
double frequency piece,
and you're going to pull out
just what you're interested in.
Except now it's no
longer x of n itself.
It's x of n multiplied
by this cosine.
So can you see that this
could lead you into trouble?
What's the worst case here?
Sorry, worst case-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE: Yeah,
if phi is pi over 2,
then cosine phi is 0, and
you get nothing, all right?
So if you're unlucky
in the offset
between your local sinusoid
and the sinusoid that
was used at the transmitter, you
could end up with nothing, OK?
You can also get
the negative of what
was sent, and so
on, so you can go
through the whole set
of possibilities there.
So the case of a phase
error of pi over 2
corresponds to looking
at a signal that
was transmitted on a cosine and
multiplying it by a sine, OK?
And you can think through
that in the spectral setting,
as well.
Maybe you'll do some
of this in recitation,
or maybe you already have.
But when you multiply by a
sine in the spectral domain--
So if you've got--
you've got your
received signal, r of n,
and now you're multiplying
it by sine omega c n, right?
Sine omega c n, well, that's
1 over 2j e to the j omega
c n minus e to the minus
j omega c n, right?
So in the spectral
domain, what happens?
Well, you've got r of n
multiplied by 1 over 2j times
this first exponential.
In the spectral domain,
that does a shifting
and a multiplying by 1
over 2j, and then you've
got this term doing
the same kind of thing.
So you're going to have a
shift of the spectrum of r of n
in the frequency domain
and a scaling by 1 over 2j.
So if you think through what
the shifting and scaling does,
you see that it's
a little bit more
of a complicated picture
of what you had over here.
Well, the real part gets
replicated around the 2 omega c
region, but flipped over.
The imaginary part gets
carried over intact.
And then the replications
around minus 2-- sorry,
around minus omega c, that is--
the imaginary part
gets flipped over,
and the real part gets
carried over directly.
Except what was real before
becomes imaginary now.
What was imaginary
before becomes real now.
So you can track
through all of that.
And it just comes from applying
the standard DTFT results
to what the spectrum of the
product of an r of n and this
is, OK?
But the interesting
thing is now,
the two replications,
when you sum them up,
will leave you with nothing
at 0 because this piece here
will cancel out exactly
with that piece there.
So if you think through in
the spectral domain what's
going on, you'll
understand exactly
that if you've put your
signal on the cosine
and you demodulate
with a sign, you're
going to get nothing in
that lowpass region, OK?
So that's just the same
result but seen spectrally.
All right, so that's
uncertainty between the phase
of the transmitter and
the phase of the receiver.
Here's another thing that
has a similar effect, which
is an unknown delay
on the channel, OK?
So at the transmitting end,
you've got your baseband signal
multiplying the carrier.
This is what's transmitted.
But then you have a
time delay, let's say
D samples, capital D samples.
So then what's received is
actually t of n minus D,
and that's what's
going to get multiplied
by the local carrier.
And I'm assuming for now that
you have the phase, so we can
bring them both together later.
But I'm assuming now there's
no phase out locally,
but there's an unknown
delay on the channel.
And you can see it's going
to be the same kind of thing.
You've got a cosine
times a cosine,
and the arguments are slightly
different from each other.
And you use the
same trig identity,
and what you find is the
output of this process
is not the input
delayed, which is what
you would like to get ideally.
You aren't going to
compensate for the delay
with a causal filter, but
it's also going to be scaled.
And it's going to be scaled by
an unknown amount that depends
on that delay, all right?
So it's the same kind
of thing that happens.
So the question is, how
do we get around this?
And here's one idea
that works well,
and which you're actually
exploring in the lab.
Which is to use both the
sine and the cosine, OK?
So use both the sign on
the cosine to demodulate.
If you go completely
bad on one channel
because you've got the
phase completely wrong
with the cosine,
you're going to do
all right on the sine channel.
If you do completely
bad on the sine channel
because you've got
the phase wrong,
then you're going to do all
right on the cosine channel.
So at least one
of them will work,
and more typically both of
them will work a little bit,
and what you'll then do is
combine the two outputs.
OK?
So you're going to have
the signal coming in.
There's a cosine multiplication
and the sine multiplication,
and then the lowpass filtering.
We refer to this as
the in-phase component,
assuming that you were
modulating on a cosine,
and this is referred to as
the quadrature component.
So there's in-phase
and quadrature.
"Quadrature" just
means at right angles.
So this is the I and
the Q components.
And if you work out what
these are, assuming now
that there's both a time
delay and a phase offset,
you can see that the
in-phase component
will be the signal that
you want, but multiplied
by cosine phi.
The quadrature component
will be the signal
that you want, but
multiplied by sine phi.
And from there, it's
not so hard to imagine
that you could actually get
back to the signal of interest.
And here's one way to
do it that works fine
if you've got on-off signaling.
So what you would do is,
here's the I. Here's the Q.
And I've just represented
it graphically here.
This is typical to do.
So here is the I component.
Here is the Q component.
And you could take the
root sum of squares
to basically get rid of that
sine theta and cosine theta
term, right?
So what that's going to give
you is the absolute value of x
of n minus D. So you
can certainly get back
the absolute value of what was
used to modulate the carrier,
and that may be all you need.
If you have on-off signaling,
that's all you need.
If your modulating signal
never goes negative,
its absolute value is the same
as the signal, so this is fine.
So what you will discover is
that you get some signal out
there, and you're
looking for its length.
When the length is non-zero,
you say you have a 1 cent.
When the length of 0, you
say you have a 0 cent.
In the presence of
noise, of course,
it won't be exactly
at the origin.
There might be some
cloud of points there.
And similarly for the 1 level.
What if you were interested
in the polarity, though?
So suppose it mattered to
you whether the signal was
positive or negative.
Well, you could then
just plot the point
and don't take the magnitude.
So you'll get something that
looks a bit more like this.
OK?
So what you'll have
is, when a 1 is sent,
perhaps you'll get that value
in the absence of noise.
When a minus 1 is
sent-- sorry, when
a 0 is sent,
corresponding to minus 1,
this is what you'd get.
This is-- sorry, I
should have said that.
This is assuming bipolar
signaling, right?
Bipolar signaling
is the case where
you're interested in
the sign of the signal.
You use plus 1 to send a 1.
You use minus 1 to send a 0, OK?
So you get some
diagram like this.
The only problem here is, if
you've got uncertain phase
and delay, you actually don't
know which of these two points
corresponds to the
plus 1 and which
corresponds to the minus 1.
So there's that
additional ambiguity
that needs to
somehow be resolved,
and there are different
procedures you might use.
You could, for instance,
have some preamble
with a sign that's agreed
on and use that as a basis
for figuring out which is a
plus and which is a minus.
And there are other ways of
doing it, as well, where what's
called differential coding,
where basically it's
not where that is, but
whether it flips over
to the other side or
not that signals a bit.
And so what you could
do is, to transmit a 1,
you'll step the phase by pi,
and that can be detected,
and to transmit a
0, you don't change
the phase in the next bit slot.
So if from one bit slot to
the next the dot stays there,
you know you've
just received a 0.
If from one bit
slot to the next it
flips over to the
other side, you
know you've just
received a 1, OK?
So even with the ambiguity,
if you change the way you
code at the sending end, you can
actually compensate for this.
OK, now playing this game
with sines and cosines
can actually also be done
at the transmitting end,
and we haven't
explored that in class,
but it's something that
you could think about.
So we've been talking
about taking the samples
and multiplying them
onto a cosine carrier.
You could have another
bitstream whose samples you
multiply onto a sine carrier.
And you can just add them
together and send them
over the channel.
At the receiving end,
you multiply by cosine.
Well, that'll only pull out--
you multiply that cosine
and then filter,
lowpass filter--
that'll only pull out the
first stream in the ideal case.
Multiply by a sine
and filter, you'll
get exactly the second stream.
So you can simultaneously
send two streams
on a given carrier using
this scheme, this method, OK?
So depending on how you make out
in the lab in problem set 6--
I don't know how many
simultaneous carriers
you're getting, but
whatever you end up with you
can actually try now to transmit
twice as much on each carrier
by using this kind of a scheme.
Could be fun.
All right, so this kind
of bipolar signaling,
what's called
phase-shift keying--
I didn't explain
that really, did I?
I said-- we've said
it before, but--
we've talked about bipolar
or phase-shift keying.
All that we mean is, if you get
a signal with voltage plus 1
and minus 1 for
your bit 0 on bit 1,
by the time you modulate what
you're going to end up doing
is sending a burst of
carrier here with the plus 1.
And then when you come
to the minus 1 region,
you're going to multiply
that carrier by minus 1,
so you're going to suddenly
step the phase, right?
So amplitude modulation
with an amplifier
that switches
between these levels
can be also thought of
as a phase shifting.
So you're keying between
a phase of 0 degrees
and a phase of 180.
So this kind of scheme is
used all over the place.
And I actually have a slide that
lists a whole bunch of schemes
that you're familiar
with, you see every day
in all sorts of literature.
You know, 802, and Bluetooth,
and Zigbee and so on.
In all of these
standards, there's
some piece of it or some
domain or some regime
in which what's going on
is some variant of what
we've learned here.
And they get fancier
and more sophisticated,
but you really have
the key ideas here.
OK, let's now talk about putting
multiple signals on a given
piece of the spectrum, OK?
This is exactly the situation
you have in your lab now.
You've got the speaker that
can transmit in a certain band,
and you're trying to put
multiple simultaneous signals
on it by using
different carriers.
So this is what's called
Frequency-Division
Multiplexing, or FDM.
And the idea is very simple.
You've got three signals
here and this illustration,
the blue signal, red, and green.
Pick a carrier frequency
for each of them.
Do the modulation, and then
just add them on the channel.
If you've got a linear
medium, then the signals
will superpose,
so what's received
is just the sum
of these, and now
you can do the
same kind of thing.
And what we're relying
on here is, again,
the heterodyning principle.
Whoops, sorry.
OK, so if you've got frequencies
omega red, omega blue,
omega green in the signal
that you're receiving,
and you multiply this with some
local sinusoidal frequency,
omega 0, where will
your various spectra
be centered in the result?
So the way to think
of it is, all the sums
at different frequencies
here will now appear.
So you get omega 0 plus omega r.
You get omega 0 minus omega r,
and similarly for all of these.
OK, it's the same thing that you
saw with a single transmitted
the signal, except now it's a
more elaborate constellation.
It's actually this
that's being transmitted.
So the receiving end, you'll
pick a particular frequency
to multiply the
incoming signal by.
The result will have pieces
of the spectrum centered
at each of these.
So if you want to center one of
these in your lowpass filter,
how should you pick
the local oscillator?
If you want to
tune in a channel,
what is it that you want to do?
You want to get one of
these center frequencies
to sit right in the window
of your lowpass filter.
So what you'll end up doing
is pick your local oscillator
frequency to be the carrier
frequency of the station you're
interested in, or the signal
you're interested in, OK?
So it's the same idea.
You have a lowpass
filter, and you're
using heterodyning
to shift the piece
of the spectrum of
interest into the passband
of the lowpass filter.
All right?
Now, what about the bandwidth
of the lowpass filter?
What should it be?
So now it depends on how closely
spaced your carriers are,
right?
So for instance, if I
ended up heterodyning
such that my blue
signal, my blue signal
came into the
window of interest--
and I've got the red spectrum
sitting somewhere here
and the other piece
sitting somewhere here.
OK?
I've shifted things
so that this is at 0.
What's this frequency now?
Omega r minus omega--
what was it?
Blue, right?
So I've basically shifted
these frequencies.
So this is at 0, sitting
in my lowpass filter.
Use a different color.
And I want to reject
everything else.
So how should I pick
that lowpass filter?
Well, presumably,
you want the cutoff
to lie between these
two frequencies.
So you want half the distance
to the nearest carrier, right?
Half the distance to the
nearest carrier frequency.
OK, so you can
think through these.
And notice how all
our thinking has
been in the spectral domain.
Thinking in the frequency domain
clarifies this whole thing.
You really would not
have been able to do
what you're doing thinking
entirely in the time domain.
Now, all of this comes
to us, really, from--
let's see.
I had that already?
Yeah.
All of this comes to us from
a rich legacy in AM radio.
We're not using this for
transmission of analog signals
by amplitude modulation,
but it's the same principle.
So these principles
actually were studied
from the early 1900s, actually.
And the AM radio
that we see around us
now is actually set up exactly
to do the kind of thing
we're talking about.
So you've got some
frequency spectrum
that the FCC is
allowing you to use.
Different stations are given
different carrier frequencies
that they can operate on.
They're also instructed on
what bandwidth they can occupy.
So basically, the carriers
are 10 kilohertz apart,
the way that the
stations are assigned.
So if you're transmitting
from your station,
you'd better lowpass
filter what you're
sending out to 5 kilohertz
before you transmit it.
Because if you
don't, you're going
to interfere with
a nearby station.
Assuming there is a station in
the same geographic area that's
been assigned to a neighboring
carrier frequency, all right?
So all of these issues come in.
Another thing that actually is--
what did I do here?
I think I--
I mashed together two slides.
But the other thing that--
it turns out, for
instance, AM radio,
at nighttime, because of
the way radio transmits,
the signal can
propagate much further.
So these stations
are asked to reduce
their signal strength, the
carrier strength, at nighttime
so that they're not interfering
with nearby stations.
The stations that they
would not interfere
with during the day they
could interfere with at night
because propagation
characteristics
turn out to change.
So all of this
business of your signal
not interfering with
your neighbor's carrier
or your neighbor's portion
of the spectrum, all of that
ends up being important.
OK, I think we've
probably said as
much as we want to say about
the signals part of this class.
One of the things about
602 is that those of you
who master it come out knowing
the subject better than any
of us that teach it because
there's none of us that's
able to teach the course
right through start to finish.
Well, that's not entirely true.
Harry knows how to do it Chris
Terman knows how to do it.
The recitation instructors hang
in there for the whole term,
but it's very hard for
one person to do that.
So I'm done.
I'm going to be sitting
there from lecture onwards,
so thank you all for your
attention, and thank you.